farm
animals
farm farm animal animal animal
dog
dog dog bark bark bark
dog dog pant pant pant
dog dog bark bark
sheep
sheep sheep skip skip skip
sheep sheep look look look
horse
horse horse scalloped gallop gallop
horse horse ride bride bride
horse horse gallop gallop gallop
cow
cow cow wobble wobble wobble
cow cow choo choo choo
pig
pig pig fat fat fat
pig pig gobble gobble gobble
chicken
chicken chicken squawk squawk squawk
chicken chicken peck peck peck chicken
chicken squawk squawk
duck
duck duck quack quack quack
duck duck glance glance glance
cat
cat cat look look look
cat cat curious curious curious
farm animals
farm farm animals animal animal
farm farm animal animal animal
you